Oh AERB in Parliament and mired in
leadership limbo but in these European
elections they're hoping to bring a
message of clarity stop braixen and yet
there was another theme at this launch
the regrets that other anti brexit party
such as change UK and the Greens have
rejected working collectively willing us
to work together and they will feel
angry and betrayed
if they find petty tribalism is trumping
that but if remain supporters have to
choose a party Allegiance for now the
Lib Dems hope is that their more
advanced preparations and activist
network could make them seem a reliable
option for voters the Liberal Democrats
will be publishing a manifesto for these
elections but in truth it could probably
be summed up in just those two campaign
words to stop brexit what they're trying
to do is seize upon the same kind of
single issue clarity as nigel Faraj and
the brexit party have done on the other
side of the political argument but that
strategy comes with a risk if it's a
straight fight between leave and remain
the results could end up being seen as a
proxy for a second vote so with the Lib
Dems except that we want after the
European elections to get back to the
issue of having a people's world that is
the only way of resolving the issue and
the European elections will give people
a sense of what they feel about it they
will not give us a clear answer to that
question
and so the Lib Dem start this campaign
bold in their message on the doorstep
while also sounding a note of
pre-emptive caution against reading too
much into the results
Tom Rayner Sky News East London